oh he's out
this is like a trademark bollywood and
hollywood shot animating animals is
probably one of the hardest things to do
you don't have like reference of a tiger
like you know flipping front flipping
over
as ridiculous as certain scenes can get
this one is actually pretty believable
that looks great oh the fire looks dude
that's so smart that's so smart
debit
welcome to another episode of visual
effects artists react and this week
something very special for you the
worldwide phenomenon the global
blockbuster from south indian cinema
that has swept the world
r
r
r
r r r for me it actually sums up and
utilizes all these crazy things you see
in bollywood and hollywood movies for
the purpose of telling a better story
like the action is crazy it is out of
the world but also it's focused on
storytelling it's entertaining because
it makes the characters cooler the songs
the dances they're not just random music
videos dropped into the movie they are
story beats and oh my god it's
synthesized seriously the elements that
you think about when you think about
bollywood movies as these sort of
visually over the top extravaganzas yeah
but it hyper focuses it i've seen two
films in theaters like so far into 2022
those two films are rrr and rrr
here in america ro is on netflix but
it's in hindi not his original language
you try to watch it lugu if you can you
should definitely try to get it in the
theater and if you are going to watch it
try and watch it with a group of people
but you have to you have to disregard
some stuff you have to throw away the
bags what you know about films take that
bag of oscars throw in the dumpster
get out of here it's trash so with that
let's dive into rrr
[Applause]
i saw an interview they said 2 000
extras in this scene indian films have
very good crowd work and extra work
there's a really great vfx breakdown in
the scene too which shows you just
excellent use of crowds wow look at that
oh that's really clever oh wait so it's
not even full of cg crowds we're talking
about like plates of crowds too yeah
they're really committed to like have
some real stuff in there this is a blend
of virtual yeah everybody against the
fence is real because they're
interacting with the real object but
right behind them by about 10 people
back you get into cg people and
composited people
[Music]
so he's been ordered to arrest one guy
in this crowd of thousands
as ridiculous as certain scenes can get
in this film and others this one is
actually pretty believable like you
watch this guy go through the crowd
you're convinced that he's actually like
controlling this what's great is also
the shot design here lets you like you
really in the wide you catch exactly
where he is which is crazy to be able to
pull that off yeah to be able to easily
see him like notice how everybody in the
crowd is wearing headwear except for him
and then great cutaways here to
emphasize what's happening right so this
punch here boom right a little bit of cg
blood to just emphasize each of these
single hits a tiny thing i noticed on my
fourth rewatch of this was to make the
crowd feel bigger you have like you have
varying heights it might be only like
two three layers of people deep but then
even further i see the you get little
bits of the flag even further back and
you're like oh that's really just a
clever way of implying more depth right
even though you won't visually see it by
having some stuff higher up you're right
and we really seem like committed to
having really practical stuff in the
foreground at almost all times yeah all
the stuff that your eye is focusing on
it's all about the particulate and the
smoke in the air that really blends it
out
and the use of slo-mo here is very much
you know reminiscent of i think what
john woo does so well which is using
slo-mo as a means to emphasize and draw
out beats and it's like over and over
again the use of speed and speed ramping
and rhythm two like we're slow
slow he's hurt and then now that he's
refreshed he gets one breath gentle
pushing
getting that rhythm back and
now we're back boom boom boom boom and
the rhythm is fast again he's 100 ready
to go shot i love this person on that
now is that comp that's a cop that's
definitely a comp wait i've seen so many
eyeball reflection shots or sunglass
reflection stops in these types of films
but this is probably the best one
because first off they're like
distorting it it looks like it's
reflecting on a curved surface properly
eyelashes eye eyelashes there's so much
detail put into it to the point where
it's like is that 100 real his eye would
have to be a chrome ball
would have to be a chrome ball you see a
camera in the reflection too also oh you
would you would you're right this single
shot still telling the story of the
scenes it is one person against a huge
crowd and him intimidating right it's
almost pov but you're seeing it through
his it's just incredible yeah one glance
and that's all he needs to push him back
yeah exactly look how many asses were
kicked
[Laughter]
all right we've introduced rom
this is by the way maybe the two
greatest character introductions
in a movie you've ever seen dude this
introduction is so dope and remember too
in the language of the movie they both
represent the two elements right so rom
is supposed to be fire and then ntr are
supposed to be water yeah he had the
torch that hits the gate before it
reveals them yep
here it's like it starts on a reflection
before we turn around that's a fun shot
so here this blood looks perfectly real
at first and then it gets a little cg at
the end it's totally there's so much cg
blood drips in this movie yeah that's
true it's probably an element they
poured down like something and copped it
one of the things that's really
interesting due to you know sort of the
cultural sensitivities towards animals
animals in these movies are all cg right
they don't mess with like you know the
possibility of harm to any animals
by the way you guys noticed that he
turned into a cg man there yeah yeah
that little blend there there's a blend
yeah real real real real real little
texas switch to a cgw
dude what
oh
yeah boom what a shot what's great about
slo-mo by the way is in the world of
slow-mo we don't have any visual context
for what should look right so you can
get away with animation to just
emphasize like the swipe or whatever
even if you like played that back at
normal speed it might look weird but it
doesn't matter because it works in the
slo-mo context so something has looked
really nice here but when they hit the
ground there's a bunch of cg leaves
boom right there oh yeah and that really
sells the contact whoa yeah those look
they put a lot of effort into these
tiger shots animating animals is
probably one of the hardest things to do
like if you're doing a human being it's
like oh i need to dance and do this
weird move it's like well i can look in
a mirror or a corner
you don't have like reference of a tiger
like you know flipping front flipping
doing that i need a tiger doing a
semi-truck crash in the dark night
this is the one shot stinky
oh yeah
the punch zoom into a different
perspective i loved it though well i
mean there's other shots of shanky but
look how good this shot is that shot
looks excellent now
but what a good setup for like a man
versus a tiger he needs to stay calm
he's a stay confident he's the roar back
yes it works every
time it never gets long the tension of
that shot is incredible too right
because he's in full flex but the whole
theater is losing their minds at this
point it's like the scratch is all the
itch that like the best wwe matches
scratch yes yes agreed there's parts
like this that are so well done that are
easily on par if not better than exactly
right
it's also shot choice too because
there's an angle where that shot is
almost impossible right like but then if
you're coming behind and you're letting
the foreground be the tiger you can get
away with not necessarily being exactly
where is his hand positioned into it
because it's covered right i have to
imagine one of the hardest things for
the vfx team and the director here in
this scene was have it where it's like
the tiger's falling asleep it's
struggling but it's still scratching him
a little bit enough that it really hurts
but not enough that it ruins him like
you need to hit that story because it
needs to communicate that's still
dangerous right because there's a movie
where he's like he goes boom he hits a
tranquilizer and boom it's down right
yeah it's like no no the struggle
continues still there is already a
built-in suspension of disbelief
whenever we choose to watch a movie if
the purpose of the shot is like the
tiger's chasing him and it's not selling
a big story beat then it's like okay it
literally doesn't matter as much
compared to the story be here where he's
gonna cradle it that you can't be
distracted by oh this looks bad you can
forgive it because you're forgiving the
movie because it's a movie yeah i mean
vfx is almost like a really abstracted
version of acting where it's like when
you're in the middle of action the
acting's not super important but when
like an actor is like having a very
intimate moment with another actor it's
like you can't get distracted by batman
exactly throughout this movie they do an
incredible job of making sure to focus
their strengths at the points that they
actually need it they do that for over
2800 vfx shots yeah oh my god
that's insane
it's a nice train that's cg 100 cg by
the way are you kidding me no that shot
of the front of the train right there
that we just saw was 100 cg okay but
like i saw they made miniatures for this
whole train oh we'll get to that you
only make miniatures and you want to
blow them up
[Laughter]
ah classic gotta hit the spark sparks
from the brakes
wait so the fire shots of the miniatures
because obviously we've got
here yep but then this next shot is
quite a nice miniature
that looks great oh the fluff that fire
looks dude that's so smart that's so
smart all right we have a cg train for
the close-ups and then we have a
miniature for the destruction and the
physics of it usually it's either
backwards or like flipped or like
completely one in the other yeah i've
never seen the use of that where we're
gonna use cg for everything except for
when physics takes over that's a real
size right there full-size thing this is
all wire work but they just tipped yeah
but this is all in your camera here
except for the background which is
compton one of the tricks i always feel
like
that i see is that explosions are very
bright and often times real explosions
will blow out like you have elements of
pure white in there look at that but
then cg explosions every vfx are just
like i put all this effort in these
flames i want to see all the details of
the flames like that's like the biggest
grip
mentions it all the time it's like
it's like the classic marvel movie
explosion where you just have like the
super detailed and flat explosion it's
like just brown keep in mind if you're
compositing an explosion that is exactly
what you want to simulate to make it
look real yep yeah
right when the flames are at his hands
you get the proper hilation oh yeah
yeah yeah proper inhalation on the
finger
that's what it's called halation
hellation it's not called uh light wrap
or whatever blue i think halation is
like the technical like okay optics
terminal
all right all right bloom is when light
gets defracted passing through your lens
halation is when it hits your film and
causes the silver crystals next to where
the light is hitting to also change
color and exposure oh cause it spills
out on the sensor
film on film
[Music]
is game recognizing game game
recognizing game
two hand signals and like i'm just with
you okay okay let's rock and roll and
now he's like all right
yes
you can't start a horse without having a
horse started he didn't even tell him
the whole plan by the way the torque on
that horse
[Laughter]
there's still more secrets left to this
plan that we don't know yet see that
that that is not style that is substance
so the flag isn't just because they're
heroes of their country which obviously
all they are but
yeah the whole time you're like what
this seems excessive why is that like
the flag that seems what is the style
with the flag any other bollywood movie
would just be style with the flag
you fool what's happening here you keep
asking what is the white flag is wet why
what what
there's only one answer and that's
you tell me that there's not a greater
wingman move than knowing that your
buddy is going to need to protect
himself from the flames yeah and then
the build and then the build here
[Music]
how far is this 40 minutes 40 minutes
and now the main title hits
that's a transition they've introduced
themselves it transitions into the logo
of the film
they take a beat like hey we acknowledge
that what we just did was kind of
ridiculous that was crazy oh yeah they
even put them up there they didn't have
to but they did wait are they actually
having them dude wait hold on stop
please no they're they're holding hands
like maybe there could be a cable
connecting them that's like either on
the back of their wrists oh by the way
that's the cg horse in that shot right
there he has to see who oh
stop it has to stop and let them go off
yeah dude check out the cg horse right
and look at his little bike trainer
wheels thing so he can do his like move
every time yeah so the actor doesn't
like himself there is an incredible
scene a dance number if you will called
not to not to however we can't include
it on this episode on youtube or else
well we'll get flagged so if you want to
watch it head over to corridor
digital.com and watch the extended
version where we it's the greatest dance
sequence in cinematic history
head over there if you want to check it
out
yeah
boom boom cg get out of the way
i think they did they flip it i think
they flipped just uh looked pretty good
i don't know you tell me
oh what a shot i love it what a good
payoff he finally makes his movie tax
the british and he does it with all the
creatures he's been capturing in the
forest so this does a very john woo kind
of hong kong cinema thing here where
we're jumping through time right like
this is out of time we're taking our
beat here we're taking a long time here
right and now we're coming back to it so
all that stuff again is like the sort of
the sort of cutting in a way that is
emphasizing emotion over temporal
logistics it's anime it's anime
get off me here we go yeah
and that guy just does the perfect
perfect flip yeah that's called like a
gainer right or a header a header better
yeah like you can feel like the tension
of the animation like almost breaking
the header
actually brings it around yeah and the
animation of that leopard spinning
around like it fits can we just pause
for one second to just acknowledge and
appreciate the filmmaking artistry that
goes into deciding not to do this whole
sequence as a stupid runner
the i'm tired of stupid wonders we're at
a point where people know there are cuts
in wonders like it's not cool it's not
cool anymore stop with the useless
boring wonders filmmakers i'm telling
you this right now you're not cool for
doing a wonder anymore nobody is
impressed anymore nobody thinks it's
cool and nobody likes it yeah and
because of that nobody likes you
stop doing boring one or two super bowl
stop doing
boring one or so listen a good one
there's plenty of good runners out there
but they're used to like bridge together
and again they don't overstay their
welcome there's a purpose here so this
is like a long single shot to show what
to show the chaos and sort of the scope
of what's happening here right the
purpose of this it's the range of
animals though even the horseback sort
of folks can't even handle it and the
punctuation mark we're starting a fire
that's like a technical wonder but like
they're cutting out of it by a certain
point
fire's showing
up love the detail that like the the
power of these horses are gonna even
part like right the two most dangerous
animals that you've seen up until this
point artificially keeping him very dark
yeah in the front right there's even
this next shot here it's almost
completely that's that's completely
ridiculous right that's almost 300 right
it looks like a shot from sin city
almost but like yeah but the purpose is
it's dark we're going to flip this get
the low angle of our guy walking oh my
god
this is this is like a trademark
bollywood and hollywood shot something
flipping in slow motion above a cop this
is a trademark shot and then of course
the wheel hits oh the wheel hit him yeah
this coming up here i think is one of
the most sublime theatrical moments i've
ever had which is the key shot so the
key falls out of his hand it was so
close it was literally in his grasp he's
coming in and out of focus and then like
you can track the moment it goes and
then he's gonna come into focus one more
time and now his look is different right
and now you know it's like no
now they're against each other
how hard this hits to
boom right it's almost a jump cut to
emphasize the speed of it this is that
dragon ball z action now or like very
singular powerful strikes here good
crisp choreo with the emphasis on the
hits like low angle but like just great
choreo there and using smoke that's
backlit behind them so you can
silhouette them and read their body
shapes oh clever good point yeah
uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh fire yes
yeah
yeah
kudos to the vfx artist on that shot
every single time i see it that little
arc of the background rocket over rom's
head just
yeah it's like sometimes you're just
like you know what those bezier curves
just hit sometimes those bezier curves
just hit different and this is one of
the shots where them bezier curves just
hit different whoever was placing them
knew where they knew exactly it's like a
painting dude they didn't even have to
decide where they went they were like oh
this is where they belong that shot
could be complete chaos if done
incorrectly you know what i'm saying
like you're watching just like
the heck
[Music]
we should pause it here showing you the
rest of this fight would be a disservice
to you you should watch the movie hey
guys it's me jake again here on a giant
bollywood film set doing things big time
and uh if there's one thing that
everyone keeps telling me around here
it's uh that credit on a film set is
important you know and uh come to think
of it courtesy of today's sponsor extra
you can start building credits with
debit today now you may not know this
but it's extras mission to make building
credit and getting credit more
accessible to everybody and they have a
brilliantly simple system that they've
come up with to allow you to start
building credit with debit you see extra
works by first connecting to your bank
account so there's no credit checks and
then you use the money that you already
have in your account when you swipe your
card extra spots you for that purchase
and then pays itself back the following
business day and then at the end of the
month they add up all of those
transactions and submit them as credit
worthy transactions to credit bureaus
thereby allowing you to build credit
with debit it's an incredibly simple
system and it's brilliantly simple and
it's available for people who might not
be able to get credit or maybe you just
want to try something that's not
predatory and charges you 30
interest a year i don't know maybe
you're like a normal person who doesn't
want that in their life so if you guys
are interested in getting started today
and building credit with debit for
yourself head on over to extra dot app
corridor crew or just click the link in
the description below that's extra dot
app slash corridor crew thanks extra for
sponsoring and i hope you're having a
great day i think they got a chair for
me in the uh video village so i'm gonna
go sit in it and um make comments that i
don't really understand hey guys
i would love to hear what your favorite
parts about yeah just talk about yeah
let's just talk about the movie i just
want people i just want you guys to talk
to me about the movie tell me what you
think of it tell me your stories how did
you discover it where'd you watch it was
it awesome you know any fun facts that
you want to share with other viewers or
ourselves uh yeah enlighten us we we
barely scratched the surface there's
multiple scenes which i would even argue
are even better scenes than everything
we just watched and we will leave them
for you to discover with you and your
friends you and your friends in a movie
theater just try and get as many people
together as you can because this is a
movie that you will want to stand up and
scream at yeah consider subscribing what
you're welcome
you're welcome if you hadn't heard about
this movie at this point this is driving
you the washington movie you're welcome
this all started here it started with
this man being like hey guys i've
discovered something i think you need to
see it
i pushed hard for this movie i continue
to push hard for this movie because i
want more movies like this i hope you've
enjoyed this episode i hope you enjoy
the movie i hope you seek it out i hope
you have a good time with it i hope you
subscribe to these good boys all right
thanks for watching everybody freddie
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me man i'm glad any any chance i can see
the watch frames of this movie and learn
more about it i will take it